- If you want it, if you wanna live
the life that you wanna win,
the answer's always going to be more
until you're fuckin' satisfied.
(gentle music)
If you understand business,
businesses need to evolve
or they all die, no matter who they are.
That I'm outrageously confident in,
because that's all I know.
I don't know why one would
try to maximize money
in the short term for
their inevitable death.
Put in your phone number right now
and I will answer one
small business question
while I wait for this meeting.
I just snuck in this little session.
Look dude, you can do anything
as long as you're producing content
and communicating to the right people.
- Mm.
- Like, you can do anything.
It's about creating the communications
and building awareness around it.
- So more content?
- More fucking,
I love that, that was the way, honestly,
for all the people
watching now on Instagram,
the fact that that's
the way you answered it
made my heart smile, yes.
If you want it, if you wanna live
the life that you wanna win,
the answer's always going to be more
until you're fuckin' satisfied.
(gentle music)
If you really look back at
early restaurant behavior
when QSRs, McDonald's, the
menus were massively limited
for the reasons they were back then.
And then what always happens?
You overextend yourself, right?
I don't know, and I don't know
the catering capabilities,
the cooks, like the details,
but if you told me, the
people that make our food,
like the one that's locked
in, the cook, she or he,
the single best thing they do in the world
is make a roast beef sandwich,
I would create a restaurant
that's completely predicated
on the roast beef sandwich.
I would make the roast beef sandwich
the famous thing of your catering,
because now you've got it nice and tight
and you're using the capabilities
on both sides, right?
Like all of this is gonna happen,
especially in fucking New York,
that's all these fucking characters want,
is a singular expertise place.
(woman laughs)
Like if you told me right now
the hottest restaurant
in Manhattan was Ketchup
and you'd go there and you eat ketchup,
I'd be like, the fucking hipsters.
(group laughs)
Right?
I actually believe that would
work, what I've just said,
because, mainly because I
know everybody would come
just for the Instagram photos,
(laughs) like bring your own.
By the way, that's fucking amazing,
if you had a restaurant where people
are buying ketchup
- That's where the guys go.
- and people are bringing
other shit, that would be,
and by the way,
- Bring whatever you want
in our (speaks faintly)
- when I tell you
New York would fall for that,
- It would.
- like a fuck, they would
fold like a cheap chair.
Everybody in my office would
go to that goddamn place.
(group laughs)
I mean, guys,
I will just say this, like
when I think about these ideas
I always do what I'm about to do.
We are sitting at a table
where there is bottled water.
We paid multiple dollars
for water in that bottle
which is literally free
to ourselves right now
if we go in the kitchen.
I mean, I would pay
anything, and I mean a lot,
just 'cause I would want to see it,
I'm trying to think how much I would pay,
I would pay crazy amounts of money
if somebody said they
actually had the footage
from the first time bottled
water was thought of.
I'm just dying to see how sheer
he got laughed out of the room.
- [Man] Just put water
in a bottle and sell it--
- I mean, oxygen is the only one,
like that's the one that I want.
- They do.
- I know it does, versions of.
- Oxygen water.
- Yeah, I've seen it.
I've seen it.
- In bars.
- Like in a club.
- I've seen it.
But I'm talking just
like you come in a room
and you (breathes deeply)
and you leave, like,
(group laughs)
like the way we,
like that is more experiential,
there's like things going on.
I'm talking like, you come into my place,
it's called Oxygen, you walk
in, you pay me two bucks,
you just, and then you leave. (laughs)
No way, this is it?
(cork pops)
- That's it.
- All right, film it, film it.
- Hope you like it.
- This is really it?
- Yeah.
- Holy shit.
- [Taller Man] It's not filtered,
but other than that it's--
- It's not filtered.
- Yeah.
- Makes sense.
- So it's not the wine.
- It's pretty much the wine.
- I don't know.
(staff chatting faintly)
(man mimics siren wailing)
(man laughs)
- We're in deep trouble.
(men laugh)
It's good, I'm really happy.
- How to tune out and not
care what other people think,
but still be a good listener
and not be stubborn?
- That's a great question.
You know, like it's, you know, that's,
you know, it's funny what came to me,
like the answer was like practice.
- [Man] Mm-hmm, yeah, that's a good one.
- You know, just like do it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, listen to people,
like do it.
- Yeah.
- You know, to me it's the
delta of defense and offense.
Listening and not being stubborn means
taking action to other
people's advice for context.
Defense is dwelling
about people judging you.
- [Man] So practicing not dwelling.
- Yeah.
- Fuck other people's opinions, bro.
- Yeah, and--
- Especially when
they're coming from people
that haven't achieved
what you've achieved.
- [Man] Right, how to build confidence.
- Look, if you weren't raised
in a way of confidence,
you need to surround yourself
with people that give you confidence.
- [Man] I think I was, and
I've accomplished so much,
and I'm doing so well, but
for some reason I just,
I know you're running out of--
- Patience, and you know
I talk a lot about it,
and most people don't.
- Yeah.
- Lack of patience leads
to terrible behavior.
Lack of patience is also a tell
that you care about
other people's opinions.
- I do, for sure.
- I get it.
Lack of patience comes when you try
to prove something to somebody.
(gentle music)
To me, if you genuinely are not waking up
90, 85% of the time pumped,
like literally you're just super,
like, you know what's so funny?
I was such a bad student and I so early on
deployed self-awareness
that school wasn't for me.
I lived a decade of my life
knowing what it felt like
to dwell every morning,
look forward to Friday, love vacations.
And then when I became a professional
and did what I always wanted to do,
and here I am working super hard,
21 years later, I still
wake up so invigorated.
I think people have to ask themselves,
are they actually happy
eight out of 10 days when they wake up?
And if they're not, they
need to put pressure
on themselves to make themselves realize
they're probably not doing
what they wanna be doing.
And then the next question becomes,
are you doing a job just
to afford your lifestyle,
- Right.
- and are you willing to,
like I'm getting so passionate
about teaching people
how to sell their home and go rent
so that they can quit a job
where they make 200,000 a year
so they can take one that makes 89,000,
'cause they'll be happy.
And what did you give up?
Telling people you own your home?
Right.
- So I mean,
I think it's a very, I think
when you hear me say that,
like, I don't know, I
haven't heard anybody
talking about that and
I think it's so right.
What?
- I did it--
- Right, like nobody's out there, like,
hey, sell your home and start renting
so that you can quit a job that you hate
so that you can afford to
maybe do something you love.
But I think happiness over everything.
Like the American dream
should not be owning a home,
the American dream should be to be happy.
(gentle music)
(group applauding)
I mean, it's just so funny,
like saving money is
like the most foreign,
I don't, I just said that and I'm like,
have I even heard somebody
say that in the last--
(group laughing)
Like if you're so passionate
to build your business,
how about you don't spend all your money
to sustain a lifestyle
that you're mainly doing
to impress people you don't even like,
and how about you save some of it?
And this has led me down a lot of places,
like is buying a home a good idea?
Like I've gone into
very interesting places,
like the propaganda of the American dream
is to own a home is fascinating to me,
I'm really starting to go down that path.
I'm like, like I'm
trying to convince people
to sell their homes and rent
and take the arbitrage and use that money.
Like what really happens?
What, you're sad that like
you can't tell your mom
that you don't own a home?
Like I've gotten, you know,
I've done well for myself,
I haven't upgraded my
New York City apartment
because I'm living my
thesis, I'm like, why?
- You don't need to.
- But why?
Like, it takes capital out of the system
for me to do things.
So it's definitely, it's
very interesting to me
of how many things are accepted
that made sense post World War II
and make absolutely no sense in 2019.
- Mm-hmm.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- And basically the far
majority of this room
and people watching on video,
their behaviors at this macro level
are predicated on appeasing
one or two people in their lives.
(gentle music)
- Oh, Jason.
- Yeah, give her the mic.
- Yeah.
(group laughs)
(gentle music)